ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on a tous
les matins qu'on a l'occasion de
recevoir le plus dominant de l'histoire
dans le secteur des bosses en tout cas
certainement dans les dernières années
les dix dernières années que quelques ex
bar est avec nous pour nous parler de sa
prochaine saison commence bonjour
aujourd'hui vous c'est très critique
parce que là dedans capable de réagir au
stress par la tension sentiers mes
preuves à vie en coupe du monde comme ça
vous allez commencer votre saison ouais
pour moi une belle accomplissement
d'avoir ce qui si longtemps puis d'avoir
fait sans déport en ligne aussi ce que
je suis plus fier là dedans c'est où les
résultats les victoires 38e est depuis
aux frères que vous mangez pas rater un
départ en coupe du monde donc j'ai fait
l'essai en ligne sans blessure en
restant santé donc connaissez la
montagne qu'on essaye de l'organisation
mais quand même est-ce que ce que ça
représente le boudy 200e to me regardez
moi je le dis 100e épreuve tout le monde
vous le dira ça aurait été qu'ils
partent ou est-ce que ça vous remet un
stress additionnel renom 06 endroit que
je connais vraiment bien puis j'ai
toujours veillé par formé là bas mais ça
met pas une pression de plus c'est sûr
je veux bien performé parce que c'est un
c'est un chiffre qui est rond mais ça
change pas grand chose pour moi en
finlande dans cette poule j'ai toujours
bien performé je te dirais que c'est
comme quand nadal et il veut jouer à
roland garros après pour moi c'est le
même haruko j'ai mon premier podium en
coupe du monde là bas j'ai battu le
record de tous les temps ma 50e victoire
en dernière la boîte donc a eu beaucoup
de grande première pour moi en finlande
donc je suis prêt à attaquer centième
départ à rencontrer le père noël sur le
podium s'éloigne faut s'asseoir et
parler là
on a eu david singer tuteur qui lui sait
toujours où il est dans l'espace
dans votre cas il paraît que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé cet aspect là locaux
dès la saison morte pour pour être
meilleurs en fait on fait ça tout le
temps tu aimais force les sauts peut
être dans les heures puis me retrouver
puis même si je me perds d'un truc de
réussir à tomber sur mes pieds
mais en fait c'est juste pour avoir un
petit peu plus de sous dans mon match
arrière en fait j'ai travaillé beaucoup
sur des groupes seraient différents
types de rotation avec des prises de ski
dans les heurts je veux les incorporer
dans mes descentes l'année je sais que
les juges vont être plus payant envers
ses soldats donc son prêt j'en ai
plusieurs puis un ange et je sorte
d'arriver en finlande puis les effectuer
pour moi c'est c'est des choses qui vont
une nouvelle en coupe du monde que des
sous que j'ai jamais course et donc sa
garde la motivation vraiment vraiment
autres pour moi puis non j'ai juste hâte
de voir comment ça va se courir parce
que moi je me sens super à l'aise à
faire ces nouveaux trucs là si on devait
expliquer aux français le poma temps de
83 ans que c'est qu'un crabe un grave en
fait là on voit ça à la télé les trucs
qui ont aucun grave donc examens
impériaux arrière avec deux vrilles aux
intérieurs et avec trois vraies comme on
voit présentement
la différence avec un grave en fait
c'est un touché du ski donc je vais
sauter dans les airs attrapé mon ski
avec ma main puis à plusieurs variations
je peux attraper le déraillement ski le
des vins comme un peu on voit en
slopestyle justement son influence par
ces gars-là c'est le jour à j'ai
toujours apprécié cette arrivée vous
êtes arrivé avec les sauts des accessits
estelle début de dessau des accès si ça
vous avez années maintenant avec
l'arrivée du big air du slopestyle est
ce que l'avenir du ski acrobatique va
passer par les graves on s'en va vers ça
mais je pense que oui ça donne juste
plus de variations dans les heurts tout
ça donne un peu plus de style à terre
descente je trouve ce qui est différent
c'est sûr qu'en bégaie en slopestyle ils
vont avoir quelques secondes de plus que
nous dans les airs ce qui est normal dix
autres la difficulté c'est de faire
notre truc puis atterrir si près des
bosses
puis dès capable de skier a pris faut
toujours se rappeler que notre sport
ainsi 60% de noter sur le ski dans les
bosses et non dans les airs donc quand
même c'est bon d'année des niveaux sur
des nouveaux grave mais si cette fête
permet pas de ski aussi bien dans les
bosses c'est sûr que le c'est un
problème donc il faut que tu sois déjà
un bon ce cas pour apporter tout c'est
sûr le appui pour pousser à faire des
trucs qui ait moins de monde on fait
dans mon sport on comprend que vous avez
dû contrairement à nous tous le ski
beaucoup au cours des dernières semaines
au cours de l'été est-ce que la
proportion changent avec le temps vous
avez plus d'expérience faites-vous plus
de muscu plus de ski ouais ben en fait
ça a changé ce soit avec l'expérience
dans le temps je te dirais que mon
entraînement tu es beaucoup sur le
volume puis j'adore ça encore faire du
volume pour moi c'est un stade qui était
difficile de dun peu moins ce qu'est
parce que j'adore ce qui est puis si tu
mets dans une piste de bosses je vais
faire le plus de descentes possible mais
maintenant je pense avec la jetée puis
surtout avec l'expérience j'ai moins
besoin de faire autant de descentes
exemple j'arrive un entraînement je
tends suisse dernièrement à place de
prendre une semaine ou cinq jours à
m'adapter une piste qui aiment sentir
bien maintenant ça me prend une journée
je fais 3 4 5 décembre puis je reviens
au niveau que j'ai terrain
donc déjà se sache pas moins de journées
ça me permet de faire moins de volume
c'est moins difficile sur mon corps donc
ça me permet aussi de daleo jim un peu
plus longtemps pour travailler sur des
choses spécifiques
je suis plus vieux plus de maturité sur
mes skis un plus d'expérience donc je
peux prendre le temps de faire les
petites choses qui vont faire en sorte
que je vais pouvoir continuer à ce qui
est longtemps resté en forme puis éviter
les blessures
mais c'est tellement vieux ça c'est pas
commun faire son âge mais quand même le
toit y ait de l'équipe canadienne pour
le vrai des vingt-sept à cesser leur
part et parce que je me suis arrivé en
coupe du monde puis pendant longtemps
j'étais le plus jeune douce je suis
super dégâts puis jour au lendemain que
ces souches ips et moi maintenant depuis
juin mais c'est le fun ça c'est un rôle
différent si pour moi c'est s'est moqué
le plus d'expérience
oui qu'est le plus de départs avec mon
centième j'ai étudié puis non je suis là
je suis le port pour eux pour les aider
puis leur dire d'aller se coucher très
tôt bien manger en 10 leçons à ses yeux
pour ses 6 pi 6 po nécessairement tish
jeu couchant pas avec toutes les gaffes
et que je peux pas être là pour leur
dire seul je fais le bbcd eux mais
maintenant je suis le port est pour
l'heure le raid et a inscrit un chemin
en coupe du monde à se faire un nom puis
camions des questions j'ai toujours là
pour eux puis c'est oui c'est un sport
individuel mais on est une équipe on est
toutes les gones est quand même solide
en centre puis on veut céder avoir les
mêmes résultats puis à rester le
meilleur pays au monde ça fait une
dizaine d'années qu'on est l'équipe
canadien qu'on est les meilleurs en ski
de bosses donc il faut pas le rocher
j'espère en tout cas que quand on va
aller skier le samedi matin 7 décembre
on aura déjà la bonne nouvelle on veut
parier
compromettent là mais on sait que c'est
la date en finlande que c'est à vous que
je vais pas vous décevoir
convaincu que ça va bien aller
très bien merci beaucoup merci